you know they've got the toyota grand
prix of long beach the celebrity race
right the pro celebrates and
the the the first time i actually just
went it was ricky schroeder because i
was doing silver spoons i had done
silver spoons he did the race they let
me practice up at willow springs and
they let me just hop in the car on the
fourth day of practice and i ended up
going faster than everybody who had been
actually practicing for four days a
little just hopped in the car and then
faster than everybody i was like that
that was fun um so a couple years later
they invite me to do it
i end up doing it i end up winning
um and i kind of clock out and literally
just disappear from the rest of the
celebrity field the next year they
invite me to come back as the previous
winner they tell me that i got to start
at the back of the pack as a pro
but not as a pro yet oh at the back of
the celebrity just the back of the
celebrity field so even though i
qualified up front they put me at the
back of the celebrity field i was in
first place in four laps oh god
right so i just went through the field
and literally almost every turn i passed
somebody and just in four laps i was in
the lead
so the next year they invite me back
again and it's their 25th anniversary
they invite me back they invite a bunch
of like previous winners
um they give me a car
i didn't get the call by the way you you
were probably busy that weekend
you might have been um actually no that
would have been before you were you were
racing yeah i did it in 2001. yeah this
was like 96.
okay all right i feel less slighted
anyway um so so
i went into turn one
no breaks
i mean there's runoff but what a bummer
no it was a wall
it was a wall but i used the e-brake
because i put my foot to the floor
nothing happened i grabbed the e-brake
pull it up
and kind of
get the car to rotate so i went in
sideways and didn't take the front out
so then i just used
the gears and the e-brake the rest of
the way no you didn't yes
i finished third no you didn't i don't
even think i could have done that well i
just was like that was i wasn't gonna
stop i was like let me just try and it
you know you had to break way earlier
right so next up drifting yeah well i
tried that i'm not that good at that
but so from there i was like well let me
just do some other stuff right and i'd
done something had the dodge neon um
celebrity series and different stuff and
then i decided i wanted to try to give
it a real run so i went and i did the
barbie dodge pro series i did the star
mazda series um so i did my first oval
at las vegas motor speedway in the in
the star mazda series i did a bunch of
road courses laguna seca sears point um
and did okay
you know and and uh and then i ended up
having a pretty bad crash
um at a street circuit in reno in the
barbie dodge car
and so that kind of derailed me moving
forward in real cars but i wasn't
done racing
i still had the bug right so
um
someone like that we knew was like oh
you should try go-karting and i was like
you know all right let's try go-karting
and then i like found out really what
go-karting was like and i went ooh this
could be this this could still
give me what i want in the racing world
right i can still go and and and bust
and go hard and so i i ended up finding
a team and and sean patrick flannery and
myself and mark paul gossler and perry
king and a bunch of us decided we were
all going to do a little bit of this and
so we we ended up getting go-karts and
we ended up
teaming up with tony cart
right which is where which is leading
into us right so we ended up with the
guy who
would import all the tony cart chassis
into america john the main jean jean
marcioni right so but we
almost funded him
right which meant you funded me
which this is where
our circles cross because
we've been at supernationals in vegas
we went ahead and we basically put that
massive tent we paid for it
at at super nats in vegas
and
you ended up in our tent
in las vegas at 14 years old 14 years
old while we were basically out there
trying to do the s1 s2 class and and run
with all the big boys the the problem is
we always felt like um the engine
program at at tony cart was nowhere near
everybody else's um whenever we'd go and
put our motor on someone else's dyno uh
it was like i don't see the difference
between this and a stock motor
um so we we just never were able to
compete as we felt like we could yeah
you know scott speed was part of that
time when he was racing and
you know we ended up leaving tony carr
but we that's where we met you were you
were 14 and out there and you were just
as spunky as as your whole that was the
beginning of seeing like you turn into
like yeah go get it girl